merci monsieur le premier ministre à
paroles est un monsieur philippe vitel
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre de la défense le
rôle des hélicoptères dans le cadre de
nos opérations extérieures est de plus
en plus important totalement engagé dans
des environnements hostiles les machines
souffre comme souffre d'ailleurs nos
soldats auxquels permettez moi de rendre
hommage ici
cela nous amène à constater des taux de
disponibilité
qualifié par vous-même d'insupportable
puisque en ce qui concerne les 303
hélicoptères de l'aviation légère de
l'armée de terre la latte
il n'est que de 38 % il atteint même 30
% pour les pumas 26% pour les caracal
24% pour les tigres et 21 pour les
cougars seulement 100 hélicoptères
décollent au quotidien pour un contrat
opérationnel de 149 machine la situation
de la marine n'est guère plus enviable
puisque sur les dix sept caïman livrer
dix sont immobilisées pour maintenance
et un pour des problèmes structurels
alors quelles sont les causes de cette
situation inquiétante
elles sont multiples et très bien
détaillés dans les rapports qu'on
produit nos collègues françois lamy et
gwendal rouillard
à l'évidence les contrats de soutien
sont sous calibré par rapport aux
besoins réels et des goulots
d'étranglement existe dans le circuit de
la maintenance au niveau industriel ce
qui augmente les durées d'immobilisation
allant jusqu à les doubler
l'organisation de la chaîne de la mise
en condition opérationnelle est elle
bien trop complexe faisant intervenir
trop de partenaires publics et privés
monsieur le ministre devant ce terrible
constat vous avez décidé de lancer un
plan d'urgence
non à l'évidence on ne se ressemblent
pas encore bien les effets aussi pouvez
vous éclairer et représentations
nationales sur les réformes que vous
avez engagé et sur la situation temps
réel de notre capacité de manoeuvres
aéro-terrestres car nous savons tous
qu'elle contribue grandement au succès
des opex que mercy parole est à m e
jean-yves le drian ministre de la
défense
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le député monsieur le député
philippe vitel nous connaissons l'un et
l'autre est bien ce sujet vous en avez
exposé les causes
il y a une certaine dégradation
structurelle de la disponibilité des
machines depuis de nombreuses années le
point bas ayant été atteint en 2010
c'est la première raison est la deuxième
raison c'est la grande mobilisation la
brande sollicitations de ses machines
dans des milieux extrêmement hostile ce
qui fait que le taux de disponibilité
n'est pas bon j'ai eu l'occasion de vous
dire en commission à plusieurs reprises
que j'étais très mécontent de cette
situation je le redis ici j'ai pris une
série de mesures dans un premier temps
d'abord en renforçant les moyens de du
maintien en condition opérationnelle ce
qu'on appelle mc haut et d'autre part en
portant l'acquisition de plusieurs
titres supplémentaires et de plusieurs
nh90 supplémentaire parce que vous
l'avez bien dit ce n'est pas d'abord une
question de vétusté la question de
l'équité est marginal mais c'est une
question de délai de lenteur des visites
de lenteur d'approvisionnement de pièces
détachées bref une chaîne qui ne marche
pas donc les mesures que jamais pris
antérieurement ne suffisent pas et j'ai
décidé vous le savez d'engager un plan
de restructuration une véritable
révolution culturelle et technique dans
la chaîne du maintien en condition
opérationnelle de ces machines
que ce soit les industriels les services
ou les armées ces mesures sont engagés
mais il faudra beaucoup de détermination
tant les habitudes à ce sujet sont
tenaces or c'est un outil vous l'avez
dit indispensable aux combats
d'aujourd'hui
et j'ajoute un dernier point pour
l'avenir une des raisons c'est aussi la
diversité du parc
il nous faudra pour l'avenir mettre fin
à cette dispersion et avoir des parcs
beaucoup plus unifiée et c'est ce que
nous allons faire par l'hélicoptère
léger intérêt